yeah I said the next play football next
teammate of mine and we're getting three
properties through yourself and he's
passed me on to yourself and a lot to
what he's done and his three properties
ruin him I think just over 2,000 pounds
a month which says a great return I
think we may be floating points that
it's possible to get up to the day
except mark on return on investment you
know looking that you say I buy a lower
and higher it is possible to achieve
that I've had money away in the bank for
too many years now and realizing that
when he is depreciating in the bank so
normally to get that a return on
investment it is a very big positive and
hence while while I'm here with you and
looking forward to see my house next
choice is high five you guys are awesome
very nice report he's got shortly yeah
love I love the kitchen brand new is it
better than we promised yes you know I
expected a lot we always do here
interpretation would Isabella cool yeah
could you live in yourself happy with
returns been Sean
yeah and I'm lucky policies getting up
and running to get attention
absolutely
my I'm Samuel is and the reason we get
professional football players are bank
managers and seasoned investors coming
to us to source properties for them is
for two reasons number one is because we
have a team of deal sources who spend 40
hours a week
finding good properties and we really
know what we're looking forward B news
eight years and for reason number two is
that we've got a fantastic reputation
because we've always under-promise and
over-deliver in everything we do so if
you're looking to find good properties
whether they be HMOs lease option
agreements will be low market value
property then go to
www.prophecyinthenews.com that you gain
and sign up for our early bird list and
look for to seeing you on the other side